well thank you for hanging out through
the technical difficulties of getting
two monitors showing up so I would like
to share with you today some of the
advances that have been going on on the
educational front to the Wolfram Alpha
Chemistry team and so we'll step our way
towards hopefully chemistry mastery and
with an allusion towards the step by
steps that are offered through Wolfram
Alpha so this step by step offerings
have been growing since they started
back in 2013 and what I'd like to
emphasize is that as you see in the
middle we've got a simple word cloud of
the various areas that we're covering at
the moment not surprisingly since a lot
of chemistry is done in solution most of
our chemical solutions the reactions
concentrations are the areas that we've
been growing but we're trying to cover
all of the areas of chemistry being that
chemistry is a central science so if
you're in astronomy if you're in
engineering if you're in biology
wide-variety Health Professions all
those different areas have to have some
sort of chemistry background and so
we're trying to lower the barrier for
understanding chemistry by the offerings
that were doing with the step by steps
and we're making very purposeful choices
to try and use every educational
opportunity that we have when we're
doing the different steps to show what
what is going on from the chemistry
perspective helps sort out the math
because sometimes that can be a barrier
in and of itself but we're trying to be
able to have content that would support
chemistry ranging from the primary
school to secondary school all the way
up through college and possibly even
into the research environment depending
on what you're researching so one of the
things that has been happening in the
chemistry curriculum over the last five
to ten years
has been a change in how we talk about
solving the problems and let me see if I
can make that just a bit larger
well anyways so what has been going on
has been in past and possibly many of
you if you happen to have a chemistry
course back in the day the problem was
stated and then just the answer was
worked out there really wasn't any
details of thought of thinking as a
chemist the problem-solving steps
explicitly had a plan what information
you might need and how you would combine
it together it was just laid out well
that has since changed as we've been
tracking em aesthetic aters has been
trying to emphasize thinking like a
chemist and laying out the
problem-solving strategies more
explicitly and to to support that we
were have started to implement what is
shown here is the planned step so these
are four examples from working on alpha
right now we're for the different
problems we stop and say after restating
the problem we show what is going on and
how one might think through the problem
before we actually solve it and again
this is - so that our material will
complement that which is in the modern
textbooks these days so one to me so
let's pop over to an example I have on
the screen for those that view this
later on a static example so we'll pop
over here we'll look at the mass
composition of an anti hemophiliac
factor molecule it has quite a few atoms
so that makes it a little interesting
but if we click on this step by steps
and do a little bit of scrolling or
crest all of them for those that have
used the step by step feature of Wolfram
Pro this may look familiar
but again here we restate the problem
the new bit that I was talking about are
the planned steps and we're slowly
rolling this out into all the new
features that have been coming online
since roughly March of this year and
we'll continue to roll this out into the
existing step by steps as they refresh
their look and expand their
functionality we're in this case we're
looking and Counting the number of atoms
I won't walk you through the actual
details of things
I did want to say and also point out
here when possible we've also been
implementing Czech steps so in this case
we're dealing with fractions and so the
fractions that we've computed in this
step should always add up to one
and so we explicitly take time to show
that and we have a show details or the
show intermediate steps that one can
click and in lies the steps to add all
those fractions together so again
purposely making sure that we take
advantage of every educational
opportunity to clear things up for the
students who might be tackling the
material now if we pop back one of the
other things that most anyone who
studies in the sciences but particularly
in chemistry will run into is the area
of precision with measured values so you
go to the laboratory you take a mass
measurement you take a volume
measurement of a solute or a solvent you
need to keep track of that precision
through your calculation and in the
colloquialisms in the chemistry
literature it's called significant
figures or more formally significant
digits and since this is a barrier for
many folks when they are getting started
or when you're trying to worry about all
the details of just doing the
calculation you can get a little turned
around with carrying around your
significant figures we've put together a
Wolfram function repository function
called significant digits it's in review
so hopefully in the next few weeks it'll
be showing up on the Wolfram function
repository and some of its features that
it can do is that when you provide it in
this case a list we can handle text
numbers we can handle integers and real
numbers of course we can handle numbers
in various scientific formations and
this last one here if you're not
familiar is the ISO specification for
uncertainty so we get four five and six
or the significant digits this is the
uncertainty here in the parentheses more
details of that there we go
again it's a way of keeping track of
precision in measure quantities by
default we have that all nonzero digits
and zeros between nonzero digits are
significant this follows the NIST and
international standards on the subject
zeros employee to position the decimal
are not significant so numbers like 100
presented as an integer would only have
one significant digit the user has
control over counting those other zeros
as significant because that's context
information that one would need but all
that is built into the function and like
I said it will hopefully be available on
the function repository shortly since
significant figures are so important in
the chemistry problem solving that run
you've run into it definitely the high
school and college environment we've
been trying to make all of our step by
steps more significant figure compliant
and here again we have an example of the
technetium fluoride for our molar masses
since we're pulling information from the
isotopic the elements and their isotopic
bits we can click on the step by step
and again we're going to get all the
steps and so as you see here we're let's
see again we have our planned step we
have the the chemical formula and then
from that we do the element tally and
grab our information from the periodic
table note here that we're keeping all
the number of sig figs that are
available so even though technetium is
known to quite a few number of
significant figures I believe 11 and
then technetium being radioactive is
only known to two so in this case we
lose quite a bit of precision when we do
the calculation the final result being
193 but while we're doing the work we
keep all the intermediate significant
figures as you were taught to do in the
classroom so again trying to align our
our step by step efforts with the
current pedagogy in the classroom
so some other more in development stuff
that I'd like to show you now so we're
not going to be able to pop over to the
web to show you the actual result we've
been updating again our current
offerings to bring them in line with
modern teaching standards so here we're
doing a simple conversion we're going to
go from grams to moles it's a common
conversion that's necessary and as you
can see we restate the problem and we
don't have a plan step here they'll be
coming out eventually but we're still
working through through this but if we
were alive on the website this second
step here would have an option to show
more details before we go and show what
that looks like I just like to point out
one of the things that we have been
implementing across is the sort of fence
notation for dimensional analysis where
the grams are laid out in the proper
fraction so they cancel out in the
common way that is taught so now if we
here
as as units are you multiplying them
together sir grams times moles I don't
think we've taught it about that but if
you'll see me afterwards we can talk in
and I could get that into the works as
you say that would be the fastest thing
to do is that if you put it into Wolfram
Alpha at the bottom of the page is a
submit feedback click that button and
fill us in and that'll that'll get the
chemistry team and the unit team working
on that right away
but feel free just talk to me afterwards
so if we clicked more details now what
you'll see is we have calculate molar
mass and again you'll start to see the
pieces that we saw when we were
calculating the molar mass before so
again this is a consistent pedagogy
throughout the whole system the steps
that you saw before when calculating the
molar mass are now the steps that are
shown here which you may need a
refresher on as you're working through
this particular problem where you had to
calculate the molar mass as well once we
have those concentration convergent
conversions we could start building upon
them in the case of chemistry this is
moving on to doing concentrations of
solutes in solution so now we're doing
the molarity and here again we restate
the problem this one has a planned step
and then we follow through on the
planned step to show what's going on now
in this particular case I'm not going to
show you the details of this mass to
moles conversion that's exactly what we
saw in the last show details step but
what I like to show is that how we're
again doing the fence notation to cross
out the units for the student and then
also in the bottom here we take the
opportunity where we have moles per
liter we write it in the variety of
forms as the fraction as the fractional
unit and then also using the symbol
capital m for molar which is the
shorthand notation that's used quite
commonly
so now if we can compute the molality or
the molarity or the mass fraction or any
of the other concentration units which
we have working live on the website we
can start to go the reverse direction
and say using those definitions of
concentration can we create recipes for
solution preparation so if you're
working in a laboratory and you're
tasked with creating a 2 molar solution
of an acid or a half a mil amol or
solution of whatever we have steps that
now are working through helping you
solve that again we have a planned step
and as in so many problems you have to
immediately convert grams to moles and
then here we're going to bring the
molarity over to the units that we need
for canceling out and then here in this
step we're going to use an existing
definition in this case the definition
of molarity and we're going to do some
algebra algebra to rearrange that now
sometimes that algebraic step is quite
simple and straightforward for those
that are at this point in their career
but maybe that isn't so straightforward
for them and what we have set up is that
on when this goes live come on what
we've got now is setup that we use the
math step by steps to take care of their
symbolic algebra transformations and the
student then can see doing the algebraic
manipulations to get the in this case
isolate V on the left hand side so we
both in the step by steps for chemistry
have additional details on the chemistry
side and additional details on the math
side all in support of doing the final
chemistry problem at hand supporting all
this has been some great efforts by our
video team they have been putting
together tutorial videos to help both
the students get familiar with using the
tools in the classroom and also as
resources for the educators to put into
their learning management systems so
that they don't have to spend precious
classroom time on teaching the students
how to use the
the software so if you'll indulge me
we'll pop over and I'd like to show you
those videos right now welcome to quick
takes with Wolfram Alpha let's look at
how to balance a chemical equation give
the name or chemical formula for each
reactant and product in the reaction
with an arrow in between the last
reactant and the first product for
example type carbon dioxide and h2o as
reactants then type the arrow using the
extended keyboard or a hyphen and the
greater than sign and finally type O 2
and glucose as products now press ENTER
Wolfram Alpha will compute the answer
the first thing that Wolfram Alpha
generates is the interpretation of your
query make sure that this is what you
had in mind otherwise more detail will
be needed with a Wolfram Alpha pro
subscription the step-by-step solution
is provided in addition to the answer
you can study steps one by one or all at
once Wolfram Alpha also generates other
useful information such as chemical
names and their properties
if only reactants are provided for
example sulfur and OH to produce Wolfram
Alpha generates some possible reactions
containing those reagents check out the
rest of our videos for more tips on how
to get the most from Wolfram Alpha
thanks for watching so that was our
reactions balancing which is a critical
part to most chemical reactions and
chemical problems and then here's the
other welcome building tips with Wolfram
Alpha let's look at how to do
stoichiometry give the name or chemical
formula for each reactant and product
with an arrow separating reactants from
products for example glucose plus o2
arrow h2o plus co2 you can type the
arrow using the extended keyboard or a
hyphen and a greater than sign then
provide the amount of one or more
molecules in terms of mass or the number
of moles for example point 1 mole
glucose now press enter Wolfram Alpha
will compute the answer
the first thing that WolframAlpha
generates is the interpretation of your
query make sure that this is what you
had in mind otherwise more detail will
be needed Wolfram Alpha generates the
balanced chemical equation and does
stoichiometric calculations to provide
the yield along with the amount of other
reactants needed with a Wolfram Alpha
pros subscription the step-by-step
solution is provided in addition to the
answer the steps can be studied one by
one or all at once if the initial
amounts of two or more reactants are
provided for example point 1 mol glucose
plus 10 grams o2 arrow h2o plus co2
Wolfram Alpha identifies the limiting
reagents in addition to providing the
yield and the amounts of other reactants
necessary additionally if the amount of
any product is given for example point 1
mol glucose plus 10 grams o2 arrow 5
grams h2o plus co2 Wolfram Alpha
computes the yield percent to check out
the rest of our videos for more tips on
how to get the most from Wolfram Alpha
thanks for watching so we hope that
these videos will not only like I said
make it easier for students to get into
using our software but also for the
educator to bring it into their
classroom and these videos will be
translated into a variety of other
languages with captions and will be
available on the YouTube feed for the
Wolfram Alpha in the upcoming weeks
these videos along with others that we
have in planning will keep coming out
over the next few months to again
increase the offerings now this slide is
rather busy with all the small details
and is intended for those folks who
might be watching this later on after
the conference what I'm trying to show
here is that we're working on sig figs
that connects into just about every
calculation that we've got going we're
working on solution concentrations which
are setting us up for the necessary bits
to do equilibrium constant calculations
to do pH calculations to do buffers
titrations and the more cumbersome
possibly sexier calculations that you
might do further on in your advanced
courses but we're building up and
cleaning up the machinery that we have
now to tackle
things in addition to following tracks
that will eventually lead us up to doing
molecular orbital diagrams and things
coming out of the quantum side of the
curriculum as well so just to finish off
I've got links to all the things that I
was talking about the how to use Wolfram
Alpha YouTube playlist is up at the top
the step by step example page for
chemistry is there a second also a link
to the chemistry functions in the
Wolfram function repository and then we
have links to these molecular structure
and computation that the other team
member from the chemistry team talked
about and a link to our chemistry
entities to see what's what's there and
I should as I said I am NOT the only
member of the chemistry team it is a
group of five of us and we were working
very hard to make chemistry more
exciting and accessible to everyone as
they use Wolfram Alpha so at this point
if you have any questions I'd be happy
to answer them and thank you for your
attention
[Applause]